difficile d'oublier les températures
caniculaires de cet été le mercure avait
même atteint les 43 degrés dans le
loiret cet épisode chaud mais évidemment
pas épargné les arbres ici sur le
parking du parc floral ce paysagiste
arrosée à 12 reprises la trentaine
d'arbres entre l'hiver et le printemps
dernier soit 100 litres d'eau par sujet
à chaque fois c'est beaucoup mais
c'était nécessaire qui en avait pas
réalisé ces arrosage
on aurait peut-être 90 à 100 % de morts
d'où l'importance derrière une
prestation de plantation l'entretien
l'entretien est de plus en plus
l'arrosage sur la 1ere 2e années après
elle arrive à se débrouiller
il va se développer et il va apporter un
niveau de fraîcheur et va diminuer la
température dans la ville
donc je pense que c'est il ya des
priorités à faire mieux gérer en amont
les étés très chauds
une tendance qui se retrouve aussi du
côté des particuliers
cet horticulteur reçoit de plus en plus
de demandes pour des plantes qui
résistent mieux aux fortes chaleurs
donc on a par exemple l'euphorbe qui est
à la droite qui est une plante vivace
avec un feuillage persistant et qui ne
demande aucun entretien
on a aussi à ma gauche de l'aube
rillettes du flox plantes de rocaille à
floraison plutôt printanière pareil
c'est des plantes qui demande très peu
d'eau et qui se débrouille tout seul et
si vous souhaitez embellir votre jardin
ou rechercher quelques conseils la foire
aux arbres de sandillon aura lieu du 1er
au 2 novembre